right and we are live on my side laughs
twice
though the flash boy eat boxes what is
going on oh you know there's this little
thing called war mine that came out a
little bit a little bit of content you
know a little bit a little bit of a
grind you know as a few things people
are spending a few countless hours to
try a new so I had no idea there was a
talk about some of them maybe new
information for you but I know you know
talk about we're just messing with you
guys but good morning little early start
the flashpoint lets him get to sleep we
always got our crazy hour schedule but
we try to make this thing work so
exactly boss is taking care of vampires
I appreciate hey I did my three and wake
up's for you know weekly recents and
stuff I appreciate any crazy hours you
got a poll so it's just it was part of
life so you know it you know how to
sting me was what's going on I've been
playing just as much as I can kind of
get in I played a lot Tuesday night so I
kind of switch so I could play that
night so jump through the campaign we'll
get to our impressions stuff here in a
little bit but kind of jump through the
campaign started grinding around
feeling-out exotics playing a little PvP
and try to heroic strike I hurt
escalation protocol I heard even more
though well I mean I've been playing as
much as I can but yeah how about you how
much you have you had a good chance to
get in there
yeah man home I got it like I said soon
as the launch day I was I was ready to
rock and yeah I'm out jump in through
that thing went live got pretty much no
sleep but uh you know I was excited it
brought back the fields you know I mean
for a little bit so on you did a
campaign and right after that uh just a
little bit what escalation messed a
little bit glory crucible you know just
a tad just to get a feel of that stuff
kind of you know and um you know just
a lot of grinding a lot of grinding for
the weapons and um actually I started on
exotic masterworks I went hard shot out
to the crimson man and that's that's
what that's my thing right now we
cruisin got a nice place to shoot I got
I got a cool little bill going on right
now that's really helping me especially
enough so under level but I am loving it
yeah it's it's nice there definitely
some good things to this and some other
things too yeah some other things but it
was like as we keep saying I guess one
of the first questions I think people
are gonna want answered is is this the
time to come back and I think in the
preface that is where were you before
this came out yeah that's the question
you know I'm just going to cut to the
chase like this I've been sayin
obviously a lot of feedback out here
needs social media streets and look we
we've been saying this from day one II
like this is not going to be the type of
expansion that's going to save that's
the net everyone's gonna come back and
slack in the masses and yes it's bad if
you came into that thinking that you're
gonna be very disappointed you know and
we all knew it you know and all I want
to do is preface it is say that you know
because of what we've been talking about
the past couple slash points and with um
you know a testing community sentiment a
lot of the content creators were already
telling us like they've touched war mine
and they were like okay it's good it's a
it's a nice little baby step but the
fall is where it's at and I came in with
that expectation so I'm seeing a lot of
these reviewers and they're like oh my
god it's the same trash and it's this
and it's that and I get it this is not
going to be with you been paying
attention to us we have repeatedly said
baby steps to the right direction baby
steps
so now for the hardcore for the d1 guys
I will say you're gonna like it because
I mean is it perfect no you're gonna
like the way I look exactly it's the
right pressure at the Chris Cobra in a
chat it's the right path so it's like
the hardcore guys are gonna start
remembering ooh
mysteries Oh grind all
all that nostalgia from d1 and you're
like this is what I'm talking about
and we like the fact that certain
content is like super hard off the jump
now is everything perfect no there's a
lot of things we're gonna get into it I
know you're gonna get into it you know
that needs to be still addressed in
Twitter what all listen man I've got a
lot of things right now be honest it's
probably it felt good turn it on it felt
good playing it felt good grinding I
felt good doing my master works you know
I'm getting these buffs out it felt
really good you know even with the
campaign we'll get into that you know
there were certain things I thought was
done very well you know from a battle
standpoint there were certain things
that I'm like but what's the expectation
did we know think everything was gonna
be in this DLC and I'm not I mean for me
I'm in a similar boat as well it's like
we hadn't talked enough we kind of had a
feel you heard little rumblings it's
like did you think this was gonna be the
epic be-all-end-all no um there were
some things I was let down on but you
know some things have been in
development for a while so they can't
make big shift changes they can't
course-correct this soon so I mean as
they've been letting things know and
words been getting out there it's like
no you can't change giant things a month
before it comes out but again there are
good things in this there are steps in
the right direction and use are those
pieces that I hope put us on you know
basically a course that sets up the fall
in a positive direction and continued
improvement going forward so that's
right let me ask you a quick question
I'm trying to make it too much of a long
point but I sums on my mind
thanks that's a glow point what to get
your opinion because I'm not a lot of
thing I've been seeing also is that um
you know I'm here I'm seeing a lot of
the reused assets and you know the
people who let's just put it mildly the
people bunch of pissed off at this point
work saying they're not coming back to
the game these are things they say any
like they're just giving us the same
stuff you know exotics being reused you
know things like that what do you say to
that contingent which is it I want to
say it's a minority I would say it's a
majority I've seen out there what do you
say to that content contingent II I
can't say they're totally wrong mm-hmm
I mean it's like you can't so it's like
you take the hive now they never promise
some brand new species I feel like I
said a new enemy in the trip did they it
was like I feel like I'm wrong but I was
kept thinking we had let this
snow-covered high we have a high of
sniper which it's a little uh tracking
laser it's kind of gonna sold trippy
you've got the nights with this yields
so and you've got the snow you've got
the chilled effect when things explode I
mean they do have some different
slightly different mechanics are they
major changes no we're still in the same
universe right now it's gonna take its
gonna take fall it's gonna take that
comment expansion it's gonna take the
taken king to go okay here's something
new but even with taking King they take
enough I had some of the enemies now
they made them like animate differently
but they took a similar model right I
was like I want to see new models that's
that's a piece but no I mean I can't
honestly hold it against another some
different mechanics and things but is it
is it an easier switch for them to use
it that way maybe did that allow us to
get some other things that we got maybe
so they're different teams working on
different stuff what do you think I mean
yeah I don't know I'm with you listen
I'm never gonna get into the excuse
making business right there's definitely
somebody skins here it's definitely a
lot of assets that are being reused and
I hear the argument people like hey
we're getting finessed $20 I'm getting
some of the same stuff I get it you know
saying I'm not here to sugarcoat that
all I'm saying I want to shout out on
what's homies me from he was on the
developer update him he's on DC peeps
he's gonna go DCP recently not hammering
he's got the glasses he's got the head
now is know maybe it's the first one
maybe it is Hamrick maybe the Hamrick
yeah yeah yeah so um you know shatter
him for getting in front of it cuz I
know Twitter was on him you know they
were kind of wanna make a mistake look
we apologize for disappointing you you
know this was not the game at that
initially you guys are pleased and we're
trying to work hard to get this thing
back so I guess my mentality is this you
know should they have been in this
position no right they
should have learned from d1 and we mean
you spoke about that nauseam but I want
to say is that here what's the
alternative like when you have something
that disappoint you right or let's say
any relationship right you date someone
and they disappoint you
they betrayed your trust you have a
decision to make you have to say okay
I'm done I don't trust you anymore or if
you see this person come back with
general compassion and empathy to fix
the situation and you start to see steps
you also can't get mad at the people say
you know what I'm gonna give this person
a chance you know I mean and see because
I like the direction they're going and
that's that's pretty much what I'm
saying because I'm prepping IOP episode
this Sunday's gonna be wrong war mine
will be a topic and uh you know you know
I know we're a couple of Lord's will be
it going you know say and I've seen the
work exactly and that's cool you know if
and I feel bad for the people who
they've burned because you can tell
those people truly love destiny right
yeah they just they just hurt my nanny
like no just and the third for me dude
I'm having fun I hate to admit it Brett
I had fun this week I do I can't was it
perfect no I had so much fun mechanics
are great the changes are great a lot of
things are in the right direction I love
the fact that some of the content was
hard we're gonna see what happens with
this rain later later this afternoon but
um that's where I'm at wait man so I'm
I'm still waving the flag and we get
shot at no no I mean and that's like you
yeah you were a little broader but yeah
I agree it's like if you enjoy destiny
and occasionally you want to dabble in
it's a decent time to have some fun hunt
for some secrets exotics feels but like
a little more closer to the word exotic
which was kind of a requirement in my
book those pieces are all headed as you
said in a good direction so if you want
to jump in for a little while you know
go through the campaign check some stuff
out it's a decent time if you'd be
pretty if you've got the season pass
already it's a it's a nice time to do it
it's a reason not to and it's better
than no excursive Osiris oh my okay a
really low bar you could basically trip
over it exactly
that one wasn't hard to pass but it is
still definitely better for sure for
some parts those dad some things but
with warmind we also had the update 1.2
point O and the MOT fix that went with
it so that came out we have season three
of this live and also we have just this
week a bunch which didn't cover too much
but a couple things but most of it is
the update I mean that's the changes so
we'll start with the update and then
we'll kind of break down the pieces of
the expansion itself just so you guys
know kind of how this is gonna run
through I've shed a lot so this is gonna
kind of probably cover a decent amount
if we don't get to anything in our
random tangents and discussions here
we'll make sure we cover just the full
expansion piece as well no doubt so
we're just gonna kind of scroll through
this as we go new level cap 32 I don't
know why that's in there it's legitimate
questions like why do we have a level
and it's weird if that level literally
is only say have experience and used
basically get that by playing the story
yeah I think they just using it as a
kind of a barrier from certain
activities honestly I think that's just
what it isn't I mean yes that makes
sense it's just like it it has zero
meaning otherwise it's though otherwise
are you tasting a little 25 enemy in the
wild oh I got an advantage that thanks
so I want to ask you a question
literally when you logged into or mine
to be absolute the first thing you did
was what put the remote so baby I got my
dances together seriously the game made
me do it
okay I'll get popped up so I was tower
dumped stuff into my vault so I had
space because everything was full he
finally picked up all the shaders that
had been in my vault for postmaster for
weeks and then emotes that was number
two campaign until everything was set I
went to the tower cleared I've set up my
emotes tested a couple dances then
reload now let's do the campaign now
ready to go exactly multi emote well you
got four at a time pick them out I like
it just just waited too long for it but
glad it's here glad it's here
so I mean you guys yeah check it out
when you get in there it's definitely
nice to just do multiple at a time
they've also been removed from the vault
so it's just on your character that's
just all the changes they're very good
quality relax baby
so the sandbox you've got a lot of a lot
of changes here mm-hmm sonic master
works are a big one what you've been
grinding for there are some noticeable
changes some really good ones and
they're gonna take a little while to get
them all and finish them all you're
gonna have to play with each one of
those exotics for a decent amount of
time you know like that I don't like
they want you to master it's a weapon
I love it if you love the exotic you put
the time in for the most part you're
gonna get that catalyst if you pay
attention to what the hint is yeah
absolutely and I also like the fact that
I like this is like one of the best ways
I think they could have done it yes
gotta get really credit yeah I was like
photic how do you make an exotic the
grind before it's special as well it's
like they threw them at this really
threw the baptists they couldn't pull
that back the curtain was open like we
can see it all but it's like you want to
make an exotic special and they actually
have taken most of those master works
and they're pretty solid if not epic but
they I think they did it well so for any
new exotic that comes out say in the
fall a nice full sweep of a good now if
they do them all of them this way now
that's how you set up like the future
stuff to make you make absolutely
completely agree with you love the way
this has been handled definitely enjoy
and that there's some good ones will
dive into a few details on a couple but
we also have kinetic eggs just exotic
weapons in general sorry if I hit my mic
guys exotics got some buffs a lot some
big some small lots of things across the
board so we're just gonna kind of go
through and either I just want to hear
your quick thoughts or if you've had a
chance to play with it and loved it
which I know one of them in here yeah
yeah they know what that is you know so
sweet business
ambos up to 999 it's just next people
are just gonna be just kind of
constantly dumping ammo if you're using
your rally barricade just
cows bleats the disgusting this love it
yeah it's gonna be insane so also
increase the amal gain when players
picked up kinetic ammo so you actually
don't get it's just like a hundred for
thing that has nine hundred ninety nine
you're gonna be getting more so it's
nice i mean it's a minigun you need a
lot of bullets they're treating it
accordingly this is good no under change
their vigilance wing recovery set to max
while lasts and park is active mm-hmm
alright that's just kind of my that's
fine Jade rabbit stability plus twenty I
mean Jade rabbit so it's just kind of
fun you can three tap with that thing
it's slow but you know like a truck
right now oh I've got to check that out
there you go he goes hard against the J
master work they're not all crazy
victories I mean some is just like J
does a scout rifle and it's like if you
hit body a body head and then you get
like that you know extra damage that
that's its purpose like he said it's
good he just said not to cut you just
said that because graviton got what it
got you know classes that in its own see
pretty much everything have to revisit
it that's all you say yeah and I think
as some of these get out the while do we
see that as you say crimson is feeling
solid the graviton will get there in a
little bit some of these feel really
good point we're like okay so you read
in some of the exotics so well that the
other ones that you thought you did
weren't quite as fax them Rat King
now I'm gonna caveat this one because
they're the time of this video they have
deactivated the gun shut down baby yeah
we're done so but this actually sets a
new precedent for the fact that they can
disable a weapon yesterday which is cool
yep you just have to log out lock back
in and basically it's just gonna be
grayed out or whatever I haven't looked
at mine but you can't use it so if it's
something that's truly broken just shut
it down they don't have to wait for a
long fix or anything oh that's good yeah
shout out the Lord King in the chat yeah
a rat King got shut down there's some
perk you need it broke the game cuz
apparently they gave it like all these
new powers hitting it like just broke it
so they don't want to have it
activated before the raid that jumps off
at one so yeah right if you look at your
inventory right Kangas disabled it'll be
back next week all death yes it'll be
back they just gotta fix it cuz right
now it's just two broken six people have
it with all the new stuff that they
added it'll completely you'll melt the
entire yeah that's gonna be kind enough
didn't begin to deep on that one or what
was it yeah my understanding it's just
like they broke something that it's so
old P in certain segments that yeah
because they really buffed it and they
made it I guess it's just game breaking
so nice yeah I mean they had the idea
what they were going for is the stat
benefits when you're having running with
a packer just better and the bonus
damage
you know most of its all front loaded so
if you have at least two you get a
really big bonus and then three four
five and six are smaller increments
above that but the initial boost of like
two or three is substantial as opposed
to trying to make it an even spread
light damage increases the rat king perp
you can go invisible more inventory full
auto like come in there it's really cool
stuff to it so people actually looking
forward to it as just an option even if
you're just running this guy and you
want to finish somebody up just tap tap
tap yeah and I love the fact that you
don't even have to launch you just have
it equipped you can have its towed but
as long as it's equipped you'll still
get the Rat King perk so it's just adds
to that whole running which is six
running with the pack like it's gonna be
right I can't wait I can't wait I'm a
little disappointed yes we did get a
chance to using we're not gonna get you
guys to use it this week Liam but by
next week I think Tuesday they've
already made an announcement that that
patch will be in place for this yeah
yeah they mentioned a couple of a hotfix
things coming okay crimson it's all
you've been let's get to it
alright so I'm a big fan of crimson in
general when it first released I'm like
okay mini Red Death like the way they
reimagined you know Red Death in their
hand can and I'm a sucker for here in
Canada so I wanted to love the gun but I
just like yeah just was 200 powered you
know had its flaws yeah oh boy
like I literally struggle taking crimson
out of my lower
it is so dominant for trash mobs medium
yellow bars it is it's really done in
the thing about it is like was done
let's say you knew an escalation
protocol yeah that first wave that have
come out right
normally any other person you're gonna
get overwhelmed at some point just too
many no matter what gun that you have
this is maybe I guess graviton but even
if you got graviton you're gonna run out
you got a reload reload yeah Crimson
baby I know getting them headshots boom
energy coming back to you healing
yourself boom you killing with headshots
automatic um bullets in the clip it is
amazing and then it's got brain joining
like it's really beasty so I'm sitting
in play because I was one of the first
guns I was gonna try graviton and I
literally could not stop playing and
because you're so under level the way
destiny is now working with a war mine
getting that health is critical right
now just want a toy and an escalation
this is crucial bro let me tell you the
Lord give you a little little secret
right now for your warlocks out there
crimson in the stag ain't why I'm a stag
let me tell you why because you're doing
heroic strikes right the stag has the
dearly departed soon as you get hit with
it cuz you never you're gonna be under
level you gotta get hit hard boom you're
gonna automatically have rift energy
DOTA rift now heal yourself for crimson
you constantly keeping yourself alive
with all the content that's higher level
than you I literally had two blueberries
in a war on a heroic strike I was
keeping them alive because I was if I
got hit critically I get rift energy
instantly put it down use crimson to
keep healing myself in the cycle
continuing I'm telling you right now if
y'all warlocks out there
dust off the stack a lot of dust cool I
mean out alright I have not actually
always one of their best Ottomans ever
I'm like literally at test Everest about
the hit slots
trying to get these shots yeah it's not
in mine my psionic matrix but uh
hopefully next week because I made blue
back ten back stranded
what it's really a great low-level
strategy to stay in high in content I've
had so much fun with this build and I
literally unlock the master work I put
the grind in I got all the kills the
precision kills it was like almost like
700 kills something crazy got the range
stat buff it's a great gun love the
crimson seven hundred kills that's a
damn it's something disgusting yeah it's
definitely 500 to 700 it's something to
get the mask well that's a real grind of
it if you want to master an exotic
that's a legit number so I was like I
said that's awesome
oh yeah check it out sounds like you're
gonna have to pry that out of sturm and
drang mhm now in theory I've seen how
these work yes
watch them it's fine these sidearm
reloads magazines into the hand cannon
and if you overload the rounds they're
eighty percent more damage in theory
sounds kind of cool that is a very
technical process to get into user
sidearm get kills then without dying by
the way turn around then you have those
one or two bullets there eighty percent
if you're accurate
cool you can to tap someone it's
definitely possible and there are people
out there with the skill level to be
able to do this but as I do any of my Z
reviews there's usually a caveat to most
of them to say like and that's why stag
typically is the one that I'm not gonna
tell you is that high
now it may change a little bit but
typically something where it's like you
need to wait to die for something to
activate that may never actually happen
and you have an exotic wasted slot no I
hate you okay yeah so it was like this
one here is not to that level when it
takes a lot of pieces falling in
together and you get a kill local
sidearm load up one but one bullet one
even if you just run around killing a
couple adds like two or three throw all
or something like that you go pop pop
okay I got 80% of it a hand cannon it
still takes a lot of shots to take out
just a night shirt like run around in
PDE I still don't think this is a combo
that is worth giving up so many other
pieces
I agree to hold us but now in PvP the
people will argue right because they'll
say hey you know you get that kill and
then you get the two-shot impeding
biography view even no way I am not
wasting my two slots right now I'm sorry
I mean no disrespect it it has to hit
harder you know for it to for me to
warrant taking the cover to Agra so I
mean in theory in PvP a you can have an
awesome skill you are a beast at this
you're a crafty one of those epic PvP
that are about to hold on the render
exclaim or if you guys did you get the
records ornament that's gonna be the
first person who gets that was gonna be
epic know what we'll just ran into heart
right now and the team and just beating
everybody because everyone else is busy
at like the campaigning or grinding for
exhaustion so Maddie already got it on
Twitter I've seen a couple but yeah I
just don't think that Sturm and Drang
combo it's just not it's not mine so if
it is yours more power to you if and if
it is let me know in the comments like
I'm kind of curious what's your play
style what do you like about it I'd love
to hear so facts so those are the
kinetics then we've got the energy
weapons here's where it gets fun we've
got hard light first have you toured
around with this thing at all oh yes
when I was doing the little secrets on
Mars and you need to change the element
to shoots a secret mmm yes so that the
high light came in handy a couple of
times so it was a pretty good gun before
actually yes
I mean range drop-off wasn't there
mmm-hmm I just have a little little
extra to it you've got just a switch
damage type on the fly which is how it
should have been so glad to see that yes
and therefore those high skill people
you got somebody running at you you
actually have to aim at the floor below
their feet and bounce the shots into
them for double damage but if you can do
it I want to see someone I want to see
like a hard light montage shoot in the
ground and just little things keep
popping up and everybody's dying off
screen though alright I'm gonna take
this one because
graviton Lance is so good oh so it is
now a two-round burst it's the kick hard
it does what that ground burst the first
shot say PvP for example if you want to
know numbers is like 12 okay right
that's not much shot - it's like 59 e4
that headshot Chris so it's like yeah
but not done and then you have now
increased ability reduced recoil in the
final round so it's better than it was
now the cosmology explosion deals more
damage in cosmology explosion now spawns
little void projectiles that wander
around and hunt stuff down the little
target floats up instead of backwards so
the detonation is close to its like
where they were so if you get a group of
throw and you pop the first one he
floats up it just it's a lot of fun to
use and it ranges solid the little -
shot burst is basically like a little
mini Scout and Rob it's a lot of fun
like this is a gun I mean I had to pull
myself away just to try other things but
when I started I was just running about
this constantly Wow so so we would say
let me ask you this because I didn't get
a chance we get busy with it like are
you able to do like hard content with it
are you have you put it to its paces in
difficult content so it is one that you
want to be at range okay
you don't want to be close like crimson
I can see the thralls charging charging
you charge is new and I can see the
benefit to that but if you have some
range you can stay mobile and keep your
distance and I think it's gonna pretty
epic okay the range I think will be
important because it almost feels like a
scout like it almost needs to be what
you running into kinetic which a
Gravitron as a balance you're gonna
decide just cuz I've been trying to say
as high level as possible I've been
pumping anything there from like a
sidearm just because it's the highest
thing that fell into my inventory that's
yeah just kind of depends on the content
better Devils are still running through
there because it's always just solid
doesn't feel quite as strong when I was
using it now it's just because maybe I
used it when I popped like fell through
an escalation protocol and I just know
it sucked but yeah still I mean it's
still somewhat good
no basically I used the graviton lanes
till it runs out of ammo and I got a
dust it off man I definitely get to it
it's nice to have a couple options
though but see this is the point it's
like you're you know absolutely all over
that crimson rabbit on Lance's cell and
I got a couple others but the couple
went so good others aren't quite there
yeah that's a good point yeah it is you
know sky burners have you touched this
one yet not yet messing around talk to
me I have I have messed around with this
one so +10 aim-assist 30 handling that's
fine so you got explosive payload perk
and I don't know if that's just on the
actual standard shots so it's just
explosive rounds on your standards got
rifle like 80s those hip fire shots are
so much fun do and it's just this like
it's like a slug it's not a grenade but
I mean you're just helping them with
these little explosive bullets and this
is my gun like if you're using Crimson
if I got to throw her an amateur food
phoom phoom and just start loading them
down I'm just shredding them so for PvP
I was using it in the explosive rounds
don't hit as hard as I think they should
a little like those they don't hit as
hard it took me quite a few now the
little girls are tracking from range
that's actually really cool but I'm
gonna take somebody activate like you
need to be at scout rifle range for it
actually like course-correct cuz if
you're close I don't think it can turn
that fast okay okay I mean but if you
want to be far away if you're just far
away and you see like Point C and you're
over on a map or something like sir take
what is what is the map with it's a d1
map it would be unlike its neccessity
now yes I know you talking about yay I
know exactly what you tell myself like
out on its little pony
outside that little slope come to that
here so if you were coming from C and
you know you have that kind of a little
bit of that little baby window where you
can shoot all the way into B yes yes we
just sit there with this thing and just
pump it onto B and just let those things
head in there if anybody's done um the
one you're gonna get now I don't know if
you're gonna kill him with it
well you're definitely gonna like catch
some people like oh crap because the
tracking and everything it's there it's
a little
hard to be a cure but that far the
tracking if you get a little bit of an
art because you can this thing goes for
a long ways that's how we got a track
and sound like colony dragons no not
that far no but I'm just saying like if
you have that range and you're near that
if you're near them with the cursor the
tracking will help if you have the range
for it to correct I think so in certain
situations it's a lot of fun it's still
just a good solid scout rifle the
explosive rounds are good but just uh
don't be 80s just run around with that
thing just hipfire that sucker in it's a
lot of fun
I'm messing around and it's just it's
it's a unique feeling weapon and these
are the ones I'm really enjoying is when
they feel special they feel different
they may not be as epic as some but they
feel different so nice yeah that's what
they going for which is good yeah risk
runner have you touched this I have not
have not pull this run around so it
deals more damage with art conductor
active enhanced are could damage
resistance to 50% are conductors active
and risk runners in your hand
mm-hm arc damage resistance is now
enabled against guardians which is kind
of a big deal yeah it's kinda big do
certain supers are gonna be a little
less lethal our conductor can be
activated while the weapon of stowed now
that's actually kind of cool give you a
perk again if you have a weapon stowed
it's still your choice so most people
are not switching guns mid-fight you
definitely can't do it in a prestige but
exactly if it's on you it counts and I
like how they're putting that in there
on a few of these yeah I love that
feature that they're doing yeah so have
it dabbled with that one I mean it seems
like people were okay where it was that
it may have just got a little bit of a
buff to it I don't know if it's
noticeably better but that's just the
fact that it works in crucible as well
hey no I get angry SunShot I haven't
used this one yet you get me I haven't
that impressed yeah I remember the
tweeting is like I just got a three kill
and crucible and like so we're all
expecting like a nuclear bomb to go off
and it's still in my opinions not big
enough um you know the gun is cool but
you know in theory I mean but it's like
at the same time it's like I don't I can
keep my um you know my better Devils
expulsion moment I'm he's big but I feel
just as effective when I wasting my
exotic slot yeah
like okay take Sun shot what do you what
would you your exotic like picture of
that I know it's just a random gun like
off the cuff but what do you pick like
literally Sun shot late yeah I know what
you make that gun how would you make it
unique and now you can be game breaking
as you want but I'm just gonna curious
what would you do
I'm thinking like looks I like the idea
with the explosion radius and all that
stuff that's cool but maybe they need to
throw some like since we talking to
sunshine like what about something like
DLT I mean well I don't get too dirty
because then that's thawing now but I
mean something I mean I don't know man
it's tough I guess you know you gotta
kind of go to graviton right now like
you set the bar right so you know you've
kind of got to let this thing rain down
with some Sun explosions or something
you know I do something yeah sounds like
I could see in PvE II I could balance
this a little more and have some fun
with it every time you get a little
explosion there's a little baby Sun like
solar grenade that just falls to the
ground yeah something like that or just
whole split head or just a solar grenade
that literally is floating in the air
wherever their head was so like if
you're running around a corner
here's a fireball you have to walk
through it it's like so I mean even if
it's not that long just certain ways to
make it you need to me picture son shot
I won't literally a ball of fire yeah I
only follow fire and it's a shame
because the gun design looks so I love
multi of the yes of your ornament that's
when we come from stuff like even sky
burners which is not like overly epic
per se just I like the way it feels and
it's getting it fun like you need more
than just like all the little explosions
a little bigger like I wanted more I
completely agree I don't I don't know
what maybe you have throw luck in the
chamber on there and every soft and it's
a bigger shot here good point ass nicely
done
like luck in the like Sun at Sun in the
chamber instead of like every so often
if you get if you get a precision kill
that bullet every blue moon it just
drops a full-on soul grenade like you
know I like that have a little enemies
this is why I think it would be really
fun to be like a tester on these
situations I'm sure to be a pain in the
butt to program actually it's like oh
this is just so easy in there like hey
all you gotta do is do it's like no
nothing is all you guys so I understand
that but I think it would be if okay you
have like um that's again it was like
use the assets you have take a solar
grenade and just have that thing's spawn
if you get that lug in the chamber and
just be like oh crap the whole worlds on
fire because that would like if you got
a precision kill running up on say like
Point C and then that thing thing you
get that little leg mmm luck in the
chamber ping and then you have a solar
grenade now sitting on point see well
you just lock that point down like
Trixie lucky but it'd be kind of fun
having fun how we do random tangent a
gun that's not gonna happen like it's
gonna hold art and Prometheus lens so
both of our beam rifles damage ramps up
faster which I like nice what's for
Alice that'll be new testing for dado to
do yep very good testing their reduced
incoming flinch which is nice because if
you're holding up me trying to keep it
straight it's kind of rough you know the
the modifier from 1.05 to 1.4 that's
good to make a difference that should
make a difference so I know people are
thinking like is our new secret weapon
in the game gonna be like the be-all
end-all of damage and just by sheer
numbers if cold heart was good before
these sounds like it's only gonna be
just solid mmm-hmm Prometheus Lin's on
the other side the magazine's a hundred
it deals more area damage because it's
the one that actually gets larger and
larger the longer it's on there so it's
your Europe damage same precision though
so yeah which is going on no fighting
lion yeah this is kind of another side
so now I was watching who was it
somebody did like a top five catalysts
and they put fighting line up there and
I was really I have no idea and I was
just like I respectfully disagree I was
playing it but I just I got the energy
to grind that but I'll have to take that
person's word for it and see some
footage in action yeah so deals born
blast damage and less direct hit damage
priests ammo inventory increase spawn
ammo kills with this weapon guarantee
energy ammo drops so if you get a kill
you ammo we take you guys somewhat
limited but in general still needs to be
harder man just not there yet but again
I'm willing to be over mining and see
what the catalyst master work version
would do and then we look here I guess
I'm sure you just love hearing me type
in chat
hahaha is there anything recent two days
ago
let's see pulling up that a glorious
fighting Ryan footage ya know the
elusive fight a Lucifer yet no I have
like five of these things worried about
that one I can't find I don't look too
long right now but yeah so I mean check
it out see if it's something my missing
but again just it just seems Nate
launcher I think just I'll need a little
help so yeah thanks
still not getting too much love and I
think they're just they may wait until
fall to be like yeah we go they're gonna
figure it if we're getting rid of them
keeping and putting guns in there making
crazy who knows maybe your grenade
launcher now is an energy weapon and
they're just all sitting there as an
option do good power weapons what have
you toyed around with here both of these
two coming up I have messed with so
tractor cannon yes
alright arm very fun very fun um I felt
that the the damage was good the
suppressing was good I didn't I've been
tried it in PvP which I should have so I
want to see that suppression so I can be
kind of a jerk but um in PvE I was
surprised I was messing around with an
escalation and I was hurting some
wizards and stuff like that now at part
two with the void damage for ten seconds
with that part I don't know if it was me
or it was just because it was escalation
maybe was just too hard I didn't feel
that was that spectacular but again keep
in mind my test subject was escalation
mode it was like you know one of the
worst yellow bars yeah excuse me and um
you know that might not have been a good
test so what I need to do kind of test
it doing like a regular strike you know
something what the power levels not that
crazy and then give it a shot but
overall it felt good
I had them in hmm it's in the rotation
nice I mean the suppression I'm so into
CCJ and Dustin go out further uh mm-hmm
fireteam chat one-on-one yeah yeah CJ
with the fusion Dustin with tractor
cannon we'll see who wins yeah Darcy
no I've messed around with this one a
little bit talk to me about you and
Darcy experience hey it's like a truck
man
yes oh man yeah so I saw pyro heat a
little video is like dude there's like
an exotic not getting a lot of love its
Darcy like you want some sniper damage
this thing's gonna hit hard yes oh man
is it gonna hit hard four times damage
when you lock on it doesn't take that
long
yep if it's a boss a big boss you will
stay locked on it just keep hitting
those headshots and it's gonna go
massive so I mean you're gonna have what
23 bullets in the clip sometimes you're
like that crazy yeah which is already
insane flinch
less zoom so it's a little easier better
aim-assist or those drag scopes for PvP
mm-hmm just dump and damage and a boss
normally it would take your full clip to
do what you can do into one now yeah
Darcy was very impressive I was very
pleased I'm happy to see Darcy get the
lighting me man that that was long
overdue yeah yeah long overdue love what
I'm seeing from it man it's just like I
said it's just tough sometimes I'm you
know got my crimson and you know all the
exotics and stuff like that but it's
just like when it when it came to doing
pure DPS I believe it was um I was I was
running some strikes with a and it was
like the knock christening and to get
him out of there pretty quick into
chunks it was it was really impressive
no
I just know from a lot like Hills just
pumping some damage a new no gir I
didn't have much of an over left after a
few little yeah Darcy babe yeah if you
wanna go through your like grades or
anything like that definitely like you
know pop it in your background and I'm
sorry for goofing around see how much
damage you can dump into stuff because I
think it's gonna be an option yeah I
agreement borealis yeah wouldn't know
about that disgusting huh so reduced
lunch which on snipers is good after
breaking the shield of an enemy in
combat Guardian or super and this is one
where in a theory sounds cool but is
gonna be really hard to X Y a so after
breaking the shield of an enemy so if
you're on solar and you break say a
wizard shield actually they're too weak
what's another good one
probably a Centurion for example yeah
with matching so if you match the enemy
type it deals double damage for the
remainder of the magazine so your
standard bullet will do double damage
now if you can drop if you can break the
basic I don't know if I don't know how
you break a shield of a guardian I guess
you drop their shield down to their
final third bar but if you match their
shield type with this thing you can
one-shot people in the body yes so in
theory it sounds cool now how often are
you gonna have your sniper out on solar
and see exactly there and pick them off
and then be able to do the rest now if
you get that whatever bullets you have
left in your clip are one shot so don't
miss and you're gonna get a lot of kills
mm-hmm but it's not gonna come up that
often agreed so I don't know yeah it
sounds sounds cool but like you said
functional practicality how often is
that really happening yeah it's like
exotic is one thing like you know be an
acrobat just to pull this feed of great
a perk that's to a point where I'm like
okay I'm not actually having fun with
the gun cuz I don't get to use it that
way sacks I would agree
Rose analogy have you touched this one
I'm still scared yeah I want someone to
tell me it's amazing so it's like I just
can't mentally look at any grenade
launch and be like yeah I'm gonna put
this in my Harry Slaton I'm gonna go get
him like I just mentally you've been
scarred too bad by them so I'm hoping
someone really puts it through its paces
I'm hoping someone really put fighting
language spaces so that I can become a
believer in these damn grenade launchers
indeed mm-hmm so what it does they now
stick to surfaces which could be kind of
cool now what I'm wondering is if they
stick how long they stick no they're the
one where you dump them all and then you
let go of the trigger toe-touch idea
mm-hmm now if you got a heavy ammo I
don't know how obvious they are on the
ground but it would be really funny if
it's like a very subtle thing they're
just like they're they're not like to
have a fuse burning or anything put them
on a point and hang back wait for people
to start to take the point and let go of
the trigger that would be funny like
good goal denial style like booby traps
Lee that would be cool now it also says
it causes burn damn you said burnt you
said damage over time yeah literally
SunShot you tagged somebody once with
that thing but that's Thor and all over
again so they're so afraid to do that
yeah but yeah I was like if you didn't
burn damage over time what if it was a
prospector and then when you let go it
just left napalm burning on the ground
for a little while
wouldn't that make it a little cooler
kind of like a dragon's breath remember
yeah exactly yeah a different way to get
dragons Beth but you can just kind of
control or delay the dragon's breath
like that'd be kind of fun so I don't
know I'm afraid to I haven't seen
anything amazing on it so I'm just not
jumping in I agree Lord cliff coils to
work Lamoille mm-hmm fixed an issue and
this is one of those unfortunate
esoteric because I saw him do this in
his videos cuz it works work look cool
and you had one bullet he whole thing
switched over to curtain call booklet
like fully yeah and it's gone so yeah
with picks there is a little slap on the
wrist stuff day know that ah they
covered a few weapon perks
pulse monitor Maryland's 35% of the
magazine instead of 15% I still not a
huge fan of that perk because you get
critically wounded I don't like to be
precision frame fix an issue causing
inconsistent recoil legendary weapons
precision hand cam and just basic little
stuff here linear fusion rifles got
another boost 1.5 now it's 2.0 I'm gonna
I'm gonna cosign that because um I got
one it's not tarantula it's actually I'm
gonna say it's an Osiris content linear
fusion that is better and it has the no
backup plan perk on it yo
it is crazy powerful don't let the
impact stat on the meter fool you cuz it
looks like it's a low impact weapon when
you look at linear fusions compared to
you know anything else doesn't like a
hit hard
oh no it hits like a truck it's called
um karate right now give me one second
cuz you got no I'm gonna give drop a
jewel put a chat this one is called
trapping the crooked Fang F I mean for F
are linear fusion dude I'm telling you
right now it's a beast
it's a beast I've been that's my like go
to because crimson is taking up my
exotic slot it's my tank I don't really
need a heavy and sometimes I don't want
to use into the past all the time Oracle
and it's a sniper with tremendous debt
and it holds a lot it holds a lot man in
a clip I'm trying to member the number
on top but it's it's really nice in
Lanier's or good name I would say it's a
nice alternative if you want to use your
exotic slot for other things yeah sniper
rifles overall got a reduce in flinch
they tuned to the cameras they're able
to basically they basically said from
the developers that can update
individual snipers there was an issue
with this before so just continued
updates so activities whoa PvE changes
to play or outgoing damage basically
just as we said before 50 player levels
above you at this point most of us are
because it's maxing 380 I say that but
escalation protocol like I ended there
sitting at 400 from what I hear yeah
that's crazy I mean if you go 350 and
you somehow walk through the wrong one
[Laughter]
it all comes - like you're dead all that
stuff before a matching in in energy
weapon damage though is really good so 3
times damage with the proper damage
damage type and then 2 times damage even
if it's still energy but not matching so
if you gun shields pulled out that
energy weapon there's no question about
it
so the weekly strikes now we're gonna
come up to our first little piece of
English that I came across cuz I pulled
up weekly strikes and I kept seeing a
strike name that is a glitch yes you
just gotta exit out and log back into
the game so basically what you want to
do if you guys are doing the heroic
strikes and you're not getting a credit
and for those people who are on either
trying to get the heroic strikes for the
powerful gear for the week or if you're
trying to do the part of the sleeper
simulant quest which requires 5 make
sure that when you guys start the thing
start the strike that the strike name is
not at the bottom it needs to say heroic
strike play less always from the minute
you load it up sometimes it'll say it
and then it'll change to like Sabbath or
song or whatever the strike name if you
see that back out immediately start
again usually by the second time it'll
it'll hold on heroic track play list and
it does that then you will get the
credit for completing a strike and yeah
I learned that the hard way very
painfully the caucus underleveled
nothing I said okay you know what I'm
going to bed yeah they do have the
modifiers though which are good actually
have you dabbled with the modifiers to
see how they feel um I I've experienced
them um the one I forgot the name of it
there's one that's just really
disgusting that's against you that is
the one the one that you that you can't
jump I believe there I'll look him up
while you keep yeah
it's one way you if you jump around it
from like yeah bro loaded damage I
remember let me tell you that strike for
a medium where you got a fight that
cabal up in that kind of like elevated
area where you can fall off the map he
has a gun that shoots you off the map
shoot you all over the place
yeah Oh three probabilities yeah I think
that's maybe if it you know yeah the
mercury one yes
yes it has three probabilities with the
kebab you defend your Julian the whole
time well I had to do that with two
blueberries grounded some other evil
perks but grounded was the one and I
wanted to throw my control that
discussion I hunted percent believe you
see there's ones I haven't even thought
of yet cuz I have been to just do
another stuff it was the most painful
thing and here's a sad part the tunic
one of the guys I was in there with me
he was really high level and we were
doing so much DPS but all he would do is
just throw us all over the map well if
we jump we get lasered and shot out by
regular standard ads it was so
frustrating just warning you guys now
that's gonna be rough yeah whatever day
that is skip heroic strike sit sit so
the way this works basically you have a
weekly rotation on your elemental burn
arc solar void house we covered before
now you have a daily rotation for your
advantages and disadvantages now if you
bloat up your heroic strikes now if
you're looking at the load screen
doesn't tell you the modifiers if you
actually see it properly yes you have to
hover over it yep you see yeah so check
the corner just like you know we used to
see modifiers before probably the bottom
left look what they are and if you see
grounded mm-hmm come back another day
yeah
don't do it yeah I mean blackout with
radar disable you know 20 times increase
may latent 20 damnit 22 that's so insane
just go they just let you do is a
blackout with no radar the thralls a one
hits it's discussed oh yeah it's it's
light switch all over again if you
remember from patelliday on yeah
that was a brutal modifier so blackout
grounded maybe every other day you might
do it with glass you might do it with
iron but mmm mmm yeah they're gonna be
some rough days in there yes so fun
stuff hmm now I'm gonna take a little
sidebar here go for it
heroic strikes no what level are they
three I'm gonna say three seventy
fifty-fifty okay yep know what drops
from heroic strikes nothing that you've
adjusted why do you say I wouldn't be
interested in that because the light
level of disparity in the drops Oh
what's it dropping at did I it's not
it's not good it's 335 at the absolute
max it is so here's my main issue with
this
I understand they want certain in-game
content to be endgame that's fine
and I'm gonna try and save this as
constructively as I can because I've
been text might my main issue is this if
you have a level of difficulty of an
activity the rewards should match that
difficulty if the activity says hey
what's up TF crows I said it's not 350
yeah it's like cos 350 lol so if the
activity is 350 I should get gear that
matches 350 that is my only ask of that
nothing else but that would actually
give me a reason and everyone else to be
like hey we haven't grinded strikes in a
while but they're dropping 350 I just
hit that soft cap at 340 well if you go
to heroic strikes and you're gonna work
through some of these rough modifiers
absolute if people grind the crap out of
a brutal modifier because they can get
something from it absolutely and and and
you take away the whole reason no you're
preaching you're preaching right now
innit
here's the thing that's really you know
discouraging about is because we do
completing a heroic strike underleveled
is one of the greatest feelings of
accomplishment
like you really feel like you've been to
a war you survived that bad boy you know
and they have those kind of drops and
I'm just gonna I'm gonna try to give
them a benefit that only for the simple
fact that it's gotta be an oversight
like right why would you not have heroic
strikes I mean I know they they took
long to get the modifiers in you know
but they've got a shot the cactus II had
a great tweet like they've got to get
the loot up and they've got to get the
rewards the incentive to do it up like
it just has to be better like you that
that needs to be to help you from that
soft cap to get you you should be able
to do homework strikes and then kind of
get you in that grind to be able to now
get ready for in-game activities yeah
you know and it needs to be it needs to
be fixed I'm confident they will fix
this but it was really surprising to see
that I was a psych well well you wanna
know what difficulty the regular
nightfall is hitting it right now
real yes I just looked at it real quick
cuz like oh these are rough like let me
just at nightfall is like oh what's the
new level 3 7 it's like or 270 I'm like
I think prestige is 360 but normal it
normal didn't change I can go solo right
now probably it's arms dealer have done
it so at least I know I eventually would
might take me 45 minutes to solo up but
I will get there mm-hmm
but that was my main issue is like this
heroic strike modifiers who are coming
back but you give me no reason to bash
my head against that wall Creech I'm
literally just forced to do it
because I'm on the sleeper simulant path
and yeah and that's the only reason
people will yeah other than that I would
have I would be in no there'll be no
business for me to be in there I'm
forced right now because you know I'm
such a sleeper fiend I know so I just
like but yeah I feel you payment
definitely the modifiers are cool it
definitely cranks them up for a
challenge but if you're gonna give me a
challenge once again give me a reason
that matters
mmm-hmm so it's like if I'm gonna go
ramp up my character why am i if I get
sleeper simulant once and outside of my
milestones to ramp up is there any other
reason for me to run strikes nope nope
so yeah
fix it and speaking of strikes
mm what strikes did we get with this
expansion with care to pray tell the
audience as to the wonders our new
strikes I'll let you say clearly the
body may have known these strikes that
were in curse of Osiris were missions
three and four mm-hmm I don't know
exactly what number the strikes are but
they're both missions again and now
here's one of those pieces and I was
literally listening to something
recently like in the last 24 hours that
basically said Vicarious Visions
got their hands in the middle of this
and they've been working this thing on
for a couple years I don't know how long
DT was in development and all those
pieces but I know they were too far into
it to be like oh people don't like
strikes that are missions that's weird
so I mean they have probably had that
you know directive to say hey do this
set up these missions these are gonna
have some bosses that's fine now the
final strike mission and even the other
the other one as well
they have cool events to them that's
fine but the fact that I played them in
the story and now just redoing them
again let me like give me a give me a
reason for a strike to continue the
story yeah I'll just repeat the story I
agree I agree and that it's it's lack of
content you know it's a lotta content
and I completely agree and that's
something that has to be addressed I
mean you know let me ask you a question
um a lot of those armed
remember when you complete campaign for
war mine and then like a Nebraska more
missions on the map Rasputin estrous
Putin that those are not even included
correct mm-hmm
that's a problem you know I'm saying
like all of that ship they have content
so all of that should be included into
that quote-unquote strike package I
don't understand you know I do not get
those I mean what was it before like
when they would release what was even
the dot like not the darling just any
new expansion does anyone they'd be like
here for new crucible maps 3s it used to
be part of the advertising in ass
there they don't they have not mentioned
that since needs who came out mm-hmm
because they're literally missions again
and they can't say be like all three
brand-new strikes it's like they're not
gonna there's no new lor we don't get
any new information new mas sites nada
yeah that's a problem that's a problem
that's content and they know that that
that's that there's no excuse
we cannot be paying for stuff and not
have you know the content to back it
I completely agree strikes me that love
that type of attention and in the world
of PlayStation the only new strike from
the campaign on Nessus against a giant
flare which sounds cool is only on
PlayStation shout to the PC community
for understanding how to Xbox feel ya
shout out to y'all for understanding how
I mean granted it was never the
nightfall so I hardly ever played the
other one anyway oh yeah oh yeah I'm so
used to it it's just like it's sad it's
sad and I know it's like okay here's the
advertiser you get an exclusive strike
make the exclusive circle one of the
missions or one of the adventures or put
a couple together like use the content
bad other way and then have that one new
strike and you'd have a few people be
like if you did one in one people would
have been like okay let's because that
really this is just so anti-consumer
it's just ridiculous let's just just
call it what it is and at the end of the
day like I don't know what Blood Pact
look like Jesse said there's like some
secret dealings someone join the
Illuminati to make this happen like what
happened to make this type of a deal
wait like a year or two years and then
and it's like I couldn't understand if
it's cosmetics okay you got a cool
little soup there okay but strikes that
means this thing can never be part of
the night for we've been a you know
we've been through this you know certain
stuff can't be ever be exactly can't be
on sir
boria's can never be reserved it's just
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous yeah
and now to community suffer oh yeah
two-thirds out so yay
uh so all that aside you can tell her
thoughts on strikes right now but they
need them again
I like the modifiers the setup of that
and quickly we can touch on legendary
nightfall challenge cards or will be
here at Newton you can take your regular
card Andrew
place it with a new card so you can have
more options for modifiers new
advantages new disadvantages or changing
them up so those are gonna be there pick
them up this afternoon those will be
good
I like these steps I like the modifiers
being cool making heroics like they're
gonna kick your butt sometimes like it's
a work night fall challenge cards
actually haven't sir do something else
that was you know it's fine yeah all of
those things are steps in the right
direction but yeah the whole the content
it's that that hurts they've yeah
hopefully in the fall there's gotta be
some help there or if you're gonna give
us 30 if you're gonna give us strength
give us three and they get might get one
more but at least you got to go back to
giving us like most tiger and they were
doing so well the last couple updates
would like not locking people out of
activities you know I'm saying like
trials and iron banner and making those
changes and it maybe even doing better
with tests might give them some credit
right but it's just like um you know
it's like come on man they do strike
stuff like really the math stuff okay
but come on now you know it's just
enough is enough
yeah it's to a point where yeah this was
like I don't know how I grade this
expansion cuz there's good and bad but
we'll get that later we'll get away they
do we clear at walkouts for raids now so
they're just class-based so you can't
run three warlocks but the big one
vaults at 300 whoo-whoo-whoo yes this is
good
seasonal ranks are out there for
Vanguard crucible now I want to touch on
the vendors and this is where I was like
we're gonna dabble into some of the
pieces the expansion as we walk through
this mm-hmm so I walked through I've
threw my stuff in the tower check my
email we did the campaign and you walk
up to the Bala and I opened all that I'm
like all right cool so here's my you
know random exotic I get to pick for the
campaign don't give me an exotic there
I'm sorry but don't stop throwing them
at me because I don't want to just be
handed here's an exotic piece of armour
you finished the campaign it should be a
legendary weapon like The Strangers
rifle not in exotic okay fair enough
that's my thoughts when we get a chance
to get those things one time and then
once you've got it you're out
you're out yeah but of all this
inventory is slightly different now yes
yeah that that works a little different
do tell
so the way these seasonal like faction
rankings work basically mm-hmm is it
reset I'm just still blown away by I'd
have the final number that I've got to
give to you on this one basically as you
go through and you turn in packages you
get a level same thing as before it
would be reputation it's tokens they
work the same way but this time you go
through if you get like rank five fuel
unlock you know pick an ornament rank 10
maybe a weapon 15 might be ornament a
weapon 20 might be horn weapon 30 35
whatever you see the numbers keep going
up that means you need 35 packages
between now and the fall just to get one
of these weapons from them now some of
those packages may contain it but there
is an exotic ship lavalla has that I
want oh my god curse or 50 Vanguard
packages to get that ship get those
facts popping oh my god so I was like
but you wanted stuff to grind there you
go that's a Cronus in Chinese like yes I
want that ship big time is like Assad
knows like he is an exotic ship what is
happening and then I looked at the
number and I back tried I thought it
might be like 2 4 6 8 it not 50 holy
crap dude that was the same as big so
vendors have changed so that's avala you
grind in you get in Vanguard tokens
whatever strikes I wish you got into our
guard tokens for more than just strikes
I feel like that should still count like
public events or something like that a
little more but I guess they're giving
you a reason for strikes hmm
so you've got that all the hooks you
have Crona said that ship was totally
taken out of every verse I'm like yeah
probably yeah probably it's not but it's
not behind a paywall but it's behind an
impossible time wall so then we come to
shacks that was my next travel
wandered over to him and I was like all
right that's all crucible ranking
situation which we'll get to get to it
now I guess we're here because I'm just
opening the can of worms
mr. Sabourin King is live how much have
you um literally played about four to
five matches um I just want to back up
on that whole Shaq sting because I want
to talk about the elephant in the room
go for it this is ties in checked and
Zavala um all right I understand you
guys don't have a lot of time I
understand a lot of changes going on but
bro
can we have some different looking
ornaments like oh it's like move the
birdies I put a little bit of a gradient
filter on the color scheme and yeah it's
a really minor stuff who's designing
these trying to be respectful to me lazy
like come on we couldn't get another
skin completely differently even the
Vanguard is that I was like can I stand
or oh the color scheme I'm gonna but at
least give me something different styles
so I can put my own shaders on it it's
the same thing and I'm just like really
so we've got to address them ornaments
cuz I amanda seemed to not have this
issue mantasy those that was an example
a good example new monarchy a good
example why aren't the other factions
getting this type of treatment wit
what's up our team where we at do who do
we need to hire that's what's going on I
thought of rad done continue no I mean
that's a good point though and that's
one of those things that you don't think
about because you just glance at it and
move on because you aren't that excited
about it if it was cool it's more
incentive to go cry in the crucible it's
like hey I want valor it's like do I
really want those maybe I'm not if they
look kinda badass you I was like you're
in city you want to incentivize people
with cosmetics you need to make those
cause men
it's worthwhile thank you man like on
what let me go grind for like as avala
shoulder you go okay try this
what if you get as your valor rank goes
up before a Titan for example resize
your shoulder shield gets bigger
something like just and that's just your
shoulder what about the other as you go
up in rank some of these things get more
extreme take them a little farther and
you don't have to have our team do like
crazy stuff you can like you know kind
of reveal more and more as you go
through but just take those pieces and
like have one cool set and then spread
it out with the Rings if you're gonna
make me go grind you 50 I want those 52
men this ship's cool but I can't quite
just a 550d look no dude I didn't even
think about this but ornaments terrible
we got a boat we got a column on a
confident woman this ornament is these
ornaments disgusting and it's just like
I get that you're adding to grind thank
you I like that I'm playing I'm glad
that you're adding you know achievements
to get to kind of signify but some of
them crucible I was like doing that it
was like a that he's a miner killed with
this weapon and did this and that and
I'm like alright but in theory this
sounds cool but I these rewards are so
trash that I'm like I'm not putting that
on I'm literally said to myself I'm fine
with my season two or if it happens it
happens I'm not grinding it sorry yep
yeah I was like if it naturally happens
sure but there's nothing in there that
I'm like I want this like I mean these
trials trials or turbans before that
were like crazy wings on your back you
had trials armor that looked like a like
you know Egyptian I can't even think of
the right animal right now all those
things like that I was like I'm just
completely blanking apparently we just
got I got wounded so bad if just blacked
out no yeah the ordinal and that's the
thing faction around he's like make him
special a new monarchy was the only one
that's like wow that looks yes you were
like wow they took good time you even
felt like you know what they really guys
just went on vacation the other guy took
his full we could work and he was like
I'm working on it I'm gonna make these
good the other two or just like
brushstrokes we're going to Vegas man
we're out and I'm never gonna call it a
bungee developer because I'd love to
meet all you guys and shake every one of
your hands because you guys do amazing
work but thanks when it comes to the
ornaments there's I don't know if it's a
low priority if this is like hey you
have to pump it out too fast and this is
what you can you but there's some that
turn out very well and there's some that
just don't and the majority don't like
wrapped up D one with ornaments from
those raids that looked as epic as they
did I know it's possible it's possible
but now we're on current-gen we're not
dealing with last june you've got PC you
can go crazy textures like I want to see
you take advantage of make it awesome
it's gotta be resources and it's gotta
be priority it's that's what I think yes
he's gonna because they have so much
stuff to fix right now the art team I
know they're they're doing stuff but
yeah if your art team and you got
another like skill set you're probably
doing something else too late stacks an
aside we apologize yeah I just want to
look bad I just want to look like a
beast if I grind anything I wanted to
pay off so yeah Kade treasure maps for
mercury they're going back up to the
three because yeah my weekly reset
videos and then I do a Kate's - video
I'm like there's I have had points where
there were zeros like last not cool
video yeah
items an economy so I told you guys we
would get off on tangents and we kind of
cover most of the expansion as we go so
we're coming up to ever verse so we'll
get there it's why I didn't actually
dive into that vendor milestones will
award a more balanced distribution of
exotic between weapons and armor thank
you because all I ever got was armor and
I was like in this thing a 40 pieces of
armor I'll show you you know from offer
them less than before which is I mean or
good you know I'm fine with that
mmm powerful engrams could not draw from
exotics released at the d2 launch so lot
of just bug fixes in general
mmm now for your character inventory the
pursuits category is a great thing
taking whatever like if you don't run it
on every character you have a heavy
weapon slot that's waiting for you to do
legend of a curious again and again
forever yes and I so just all your
inventory stuff moved over is
good thing very good so ever verse has
gotten a bit of a tweak now some people
say all that reverse is still here
everything in here is still cosmetic so
I'm honestly tired of hearing it yeah in
ever verse is required to play the game
there are minor things now I will fully
admit the exotic ghost that I have with
the 50-meter range for chests of all
planets now that not actually icy chests
so much more frequently now and I don't
ever have to worry about switching your
thinking it's just there mm-hmm so that
is one of the few that I will admit is
but it's still not helping me fight any
better I'm not any stronger it's just a
bunch just world materials and tokens
and just another package from the vendor
so it's not major but it is one of the
things that probably felt the most
everything else no I have a
demonstrative shader I have a different
dance none of that stuff matters so ever
versus I they still have not crossed the
pay2win and they've kept they've stuck
to that so but I don't care about
anybody else hats off to Bungie in
psycho Cosmetics
angley's cosmetic it's so minimal if an
it's not even I don't consider anything
there an advantage like that sorry
so then we have her selling a few more
items so a couple more emotes or ships
or shaders or boons things like that
your new engrams our prototype engrams
get no futuristic yeah
but the big piece is the prismatic
matrix yeah that you had to explain I
mean look sometimes last class basically
it's a checklist no each week now I'm
kind of curious if we each have a
different one cuz you said you have
something in there that sounded like I
don't even have remotely and I had the
huckleberry ornament - had I had the a
one exotic ship and everything else was
no good same one okay so it is everybody
getting the same so and that's kind of
thing if you know there's something in
that you want and you're gonna get up to
3 prismatic matrix that you can hold at
a time so if your current week doesn't
have anything you want save it you don't
want to hold on to the staff or the
state I'm waiting for that to come out
yep so if you want to purchase addition
of those and you're like
I want to knock out this one thing and I
know this these ten have it there's less
gambling here you can you can pay for
those so if you save three you're gonna
spend fourteen hundred silver to
guarantee between those ten items that
you get it tracks so that's basically
one in ten chance that is your odds you
see it it's straight up so it's there's
a way for them to say not odds with odds
by spending this much so and again none
of its required but if you do want
something you're like hey I just have to
have this one thing and you're like hey
I'm gonna go did you drop any money
recently or anything on that maybe maybe
Sutter what is the rate anymore I
honestly forget um it was like I'm gonna
say like five hundred silver is maybe 10
bucks or something like that of five but
I get some do that effect
somewhere close so folks I'd be like
fifteen bucks to like completely clean
out of prismatic and go for that one
yeah like some crazy like yeah mmm
but I mean it's like if you have one
thing in there you want and they get a
little dlc out of here it's just this
thing you gotta have then it's you can
you know you don't have to buy 50
packages like when what are the dotting
trying to get this one crazy thing so
it's better but again not required I'm
least it's a path to stuff that you may
want that you've been unlucky in getting
yep so I'm okay and just more and it's
like I like some of the stuff that's in
there it's cool I will say I got a
random exotic Sparrow now it looks like
a jet ski basics peril I got has 160
speed but the non fast summoning perk so
I don't care about it because that's the
only part that matters no doubt yeah a
Sparrow's all of them should be fast
summoning fast happening it's really
good you know it's just like I'm
literally on computer it's click click
go I just start driving I love it yeah
those are a must
clan progression so we're at a new
season now you guys may have seen the
clan exp a little popping all the time
yes hopefully your clan is working
playing engrams only go up to 340 well
probably bet you do or don't don't
don't I do not either actually I was
like cleaning grams can help help you
get to the soft cap that's fine but you
need to play in the content you're not
just gonna be given gear so I'm I'm
gonna be a harder grind for all your
characters to go up there I'll tell you
that you're gonna put in some hours now
guided games they said there's new
tickets Emblem rewards and order all
that stuff we talked about before mm-hmm
crucible private matches are available
which pay for tournaments if you want to
set them up by all means that's not
doing it for me but for those who want
to do tournaments it'd be fun to kind of
do tournaments like you know if we had
viewers who wanted to play and be like
hey you want to go to one-to-one stuff
we'd have to get on the same console and
we are literally I'm on the only that
you are on the only one I am NOT on I
know I know we're gonna get it together
doubles to the weekly playlist though I
think it's like that I didn't expect
that either so I've got a couple new
maps they added spawn points on a couple
venues in general just easy fixes so
overall pretty good but yeah that is the
general piece of the game so that's most
of the patch and you guys like what
about the expansion while we've talked
about it we haven't fully talked about
it right so long point continues
continues story sir spots I mean I'm
just gonna jump right in what do you
think go for it Oh as far as we thought
we doing the spoilery we do it no not
spoiler I just want to know review I
don't want to spoil it if you want my
review of the war mine story you can go
okay heads up this is your spoiler
warning if you've made it this far into
the video we're gonna do spoilers now
for basically everything we've seen be
it secrets that we've heard of do guns
mmm story all that stuff the rate isn't
out yet so we don't have those but
anything else possible spoilers if you
like the game enough you probably at
least played the story so everything's
on the table at this point if you want
to turn it off
and see it for yourself this is your
final warning and go I mean listen again
I came into this expansion with tempered
expectations I felt that there was no
way possible that the law would be able
to get all the requested they shout out
to my boy myelin games then who put to
the at the destiny summit that a lot of
stuff is not gonna be a war mind I knew
a lot of it was going to be arm you know
for the fall expansion now when it comes
to this you know I thought it was solid
I mean was it great that they have
floors absolutely you know do I feel
sometimes they get to look too campy you
know what Anna did I want more did I
want more from Rasputin absolutely I
will say this the actual mechanics I
felt in the boss fights I felt were all
epic
I thought the locations felt good you
know um I felt good playing it like I
can't sit there and say like I rolled my
eyes and I was disgusted you know Sam I
really enjoyed the gameplay aspects of
it narrative Lee all I would say is that
I felt things were rushed and I was just
like okay Zavala why are you hating on
the wall mines who are like come on bro
like what you know like they need it and
shout out to Finnegan and fireteam Chad
he made some good points you know he's
gonna is the issue
destiny is always gonna have that
problem where the narrative might never
be as strong as everybody wants it to
because they don't made them make the
main protagonist talk right so that's
number one number you said it's just
like this glaring silence of like I want
to put the words in his mouth come on
say something go like it's painful so
you're gonna have that disconnect off
the jump then it's like they seem too
afraid to go deeper with like a game
like as a follow why are you hating so
much like about Anna like get me some
more let's get deep let's go you know
saying and then I just felt it wrapped
up
they put a bow on it and was like done
I'm saying so solid not amazing but game
play I felt was really good
and I was very invested in the gameplay
fighting the boss fighting knock was
riding I'm got like I was into that like
I was loving and I liked the mechanic so
that's my review of it as far as
narrative wait wait so I have to give
you a kind of a heads-up before I say
anything about the story I just finished
god of war it's all damn literally
Monday afternoon before I worked that
night
mm-hm I finished god of war story
completely mmm that that may up in a
really bad place to compare other games
you know yeah so you laughed your way
through stuff um the disgust no it's
like so the the emotion that feels so
much in God of War I'm like I just want
a how do I do this
the story wasn't bad like you had like
pieces of vana braid but did you're like
okay so as somebody I I've read so many
different things I don't know where it
all comes from so if you said this I
apologize when you load into story and
hey she's talking to a cutscene you
fight through and then you're back to
the nuts cutscene and in a breeze at the
other door like where was she between
the two doors play along with you like
you yeah like I mean there were points
where Zavala Stood Still and popped a
you know a bubble so he's not put an AI
person in there and have them run along
it's like I know I've got dregs who can
throw grenades like they've done nothing
else for the rest of their life and
landed at my feet every time people
though so AI can have some skill mmm
those people haven't even a run I want
to see them at least walking even if
they don't fire or if they do and they
do next to no damage mm-hmm just the
interaction within the story I think
would help some background I agree this
is something that addicts when I'm
preaching for the longest it closes they
can was cursor Osiris at the end you
know and that's
so working with you yeah mm-hmm so for
sure that um so major spoiler is the
final mission yes so you if you watch
the trailer you saw something that looks
like it came out of the movie trimmers
mm-hmm and the final mission you fight
that mm-hmm and it's in four or five and
I forget but it even felt like for
missions it was quick it was quick now
this is a worm God for the high worm god
this is like above Oryx to my alley I'm
not on the lure the dude is plate yeah
he puts everything else to shame and
these are the ones like there's only
five of these named worm gods out there
and he was kind of the outcast one
mm-hmm I know we're Guardians but not in
a story mission do you take him down I
don't think so I absolutely think the
story final boss should have been
knockers is a unique looking wizard yes
light was cooler anyway kill the dude
who spawns he drops listening throw it
at the other then it drops his shield
you got to do that a few times
did you know the story with anybody or
solo I did it with squid people so was
it easy for you it was almost oh I mean
it was it was meetin moderate difficulty
it wasn't you know so I would advise to
play the story solo yes
at least gives things some gravity
because you're running by yourself you
gotta like it can't kind of felt like
some work so I mean that's heart I
enjoyed so the story by myself is he
just to go through it mm-hmm gave at
least some of the fights a little bit of
a challenge which I appreciated cuz his
especially he's not normally just like
hey I'm Abbas and floating up towards
the gate no he'll follow you around the
whole damn room oh yeah he's not whoa
yeah nah crisis itself yeah but it was
just again nah Chris it's like life did
a huge lore thing on that you took him
out in a mission yeah intermission like
they're taking these characters that we
haven't heard much about but we're just
like we don't get any background it's a
name got gone
this is a worm got you you hear a
voiceover tone and you see him again and
Uther about greatness head Khan I'm like
just the hype sucks apparently just like
taking out worm gods here but just like
every day yeah daily life men and black
could be like oh yeah this thing
happened the world was gonna die yet we
just took care of that - you're right
NBD no big do you know like I don't
think a worm God and that scale that
should have been your raid box um raid
which leads us back to our problem
apartment well this will be the
penthouse not apartment house this is
why raid lair suck because we now Zolo
ever his name you know st. gets reduced
to a strike boss yep
yeah and that's the thing it's just
there the to strike losses so mmhmm okay
yeah so that's that's my thoughts on the
story not bad I mean I like the fact
that you know Anna Breit was cool I like
the you know the the tension between
Zavala was like it seemed unrealistic
yeah I agree
his was a little too far now if you go
now if you want me to feel first of all
huh mm-hm
here's some some thoughts I'm sure the
narrative team has already done this but
it's like do it's like what why it's
like just have even Anna asked us of all
why why are you so angry and do a fade
out into a flashback for Zavala yeah
this is the middle of a fight he's
trying to get back to his family or his
buddies in the war line drops a war sat
on like his whole something like that
it's like they're scared to get deep
with the narrative it's like they're
insulting our intelligence by saying
we're gonna simplify this for you right
no no let's let's dive deeper what you
built an amazing universe yeah like stop
giving me this you know made
after-school special stuff let's go
let's get eat let's let's have some gray
areas you know and I think they're just
afraid to go there or they just it just
been their history it seems like for
much good as they do they still have
Space Camp eNOS always in it come on man
is this like or is a tremendous
potential yeah you take god of war and I
know I'm gonna use that because it's
just recent I mean it got tens across
the board a single-player story driven
narrative game it can still be done but
it's like the things that happen in that
game the like back and forth between
like the the main characters the
Vietnamese the sense of scale the pieces
that we're done in that one just give me
pieces of that in this game along with
the gameplay The Rave the strikes
everything else in there it will be
happier just give me some depth give me
a reason like let me go through three
missions let me go run a let me go do
let me go do three or four missions that
kind of lead up and you lead to an
entrance then you come back in your next
story is that the entrance to this
whatever and then you have a full strike
and then that might be your final but
like make things I don't know it's just
there's no completely agree and that's
why the only reason why I didn't go all
the way crazy and I just kind of roll my
eyes or certain parts but I just said
this was not gonna be the expansion I
knew coming in I was like this is not
good I'll put it put it my critics I was
a little impressed that they were even
able to give me some things I was
actually curious and had some emotional
investment with you know saying in the
rescuing thing I wanted so much more I
want so much know we've heard three
years about rasputin's mmm and it's like
and again it's just this and then just
just the wind it's a little you know
Osiris already healing and again shot
the myelin games these are points I mean
he had bullet point oh yeah and he's
like these are iconic destiny characters
that we've heard in the lawful years why
are they being skipped over so fast why
are they not properly you know it he
just broke it down and again all I can
hope is that all this feedback which was
taken by the lead law person you know
will be ready for September because it
needs to happen all of this stuff to
disconnect from the raids the discs and
you know what railay all of it they have
to address this yeah
all right so I think spoilers can
probably be set aside at this point so I
had one in chat that
oh yeah I was like for me I mean I
enjoyed the few missions but I think so
many things were too fast or
underutilized or whatever so not a huge
selling point for me so far the exotics
have been a huge piece of fun yes I like
where some are headed others still need
to catch up to some of these new epic
ones mm-hmm so I know those are stepping
in the right direction for sure absalom
trying to think so you walk login you do
the campaign you go through your grind
and some exotics you know some crucible
escalation protocol this is the other
big advertising piece now people may not
agree about some pieces about this that
I've heard mm-hmm but what are your
thoughts about it so far you know I
liked it I mean with a little I lasted I
mean I was cool you know kicked it off
found a little you know thing you know
and then it was like you know kill wave
then for me it was like you know find a
little thing to disrupt the hive
ceremony you stepped on it ding little
sub-boss came out
I like the mechanics I thought the
mechanics are cool you know and we
trying to get busy I mean we could not
beat that older foot towards the end but
um look it's hard it's very hard you're
not ready you know it's like 370 I
believe that's the one I think it's 370
of the jump yeah and um yeah you're not
you're not ready now I do agree with
what me and you took offline cuz I know
shout out the decimal Gary he's going
hard against it you know I'm saying and
I and I get that you know I don't mind
it being hard I guess the the compromise
I would say it's kind of like what you
told me which is kind of like um you
know maybe levels 1 & 2 or doable but
then when you get to 3 Bruce you know 7
those are the ones with at 317 kind of
kicks in just to give you some sense of
accomplishment you know what stuff so I
get it you know I mean I like where it's
going I can't believe the level up and
then the really test it and put it
through its paces but um it's hard and
it's not some
supposed to be doing right now he gets
laid up level seven already though said
already but yeah that was my big like I
appreciate the difficulty they want it
to be in game it kicks my butt right now
I'm like all right actually I'm okay
with dying because this is just above my
head and that's what they wanted but my
think an idea and a compromise and outs
I don't to say hey you can get all the
armor and stuff like that one maybe two
that can be a like level three 33 49
then you start going 370 375 like or
three 60 70 80 like take those next ramp
them up really fast you're like oh okay
I'm not ready and I could definitely
tell every level is getting harder even
if it's like 330 340 350 360 370 380
like three ninety four hundred whatever
however high it goes I know it goes
crazy high um you know ramped it up fast
so as you're progressing through be like
hey I can get a little bit of farther I
played some strikes so I did the story I
got 340 know okay I can experience level
1 in this level 2 they spawn okay
they're a little harder than okay okay
we're gonna die alright so I granted
some heroic strikes I'm going through I
got it to 350 oh I can do two now threes
three's a struggle I'm almost getting
there I can't quite get there alright
fine
I ran the raid once I'm going through I
had three oh okay now getting I got some
drop I got a drop now this is good we're
getting there you know we're on the
radio that's the type of progression I
want no no so have those pieces stagger
have the things in your game matter be
like I got no still gonna work on the
milestones trying to little higher next
week when I reset I'll probably get a
few more levels might get up to that
level for help me keep grinding like
have that progression in there and
that's that's the pieces I don't have
anything wrong with it being difficult
but I think if it was a way to
compromise it that would be my theory on
how yeah I agree I told you now mind you
I don't have to promise with the way it
is right that's like my butt and I gotta
grind up there I'm with that but you
know in fairness not everyone is like me
and like that level of beating so I
understand this frustration I just want
to be careful you know with those who
are like oh you know just remember why
we are in the situation we were
absolutely thought is always don't
don't forget don't have short-term
memories I've noticing a lot of people
with something sure to remember E and
that's all I'm saying but listen in your
case I think that's a fair compromise
what you're saying e you know the first
couple of levels you know kind of thing
and then boom it ramps up I got no
problems that do a way for you can't get
used to the mechanics hey where they
spawn can I get used to picking up that
one where's the Lord come in get a feel
but then know that like hey I've got to
keep working keep grinding and this is
where it comes back give me the strikes
to grind so then I can if I work in the
strikes for a while that might kick my
butt for a little Alice then I can go
then go dabble in level three
you still got four or five six and seven
for the good stuff three is like a tease
like okay and maybe one and two if you
try it early you just get some tokens
join like and I'm okay with that type of
level be like I only got tokens it's
level one this is just the basics guys
and that's how some of that could go so
no I was like I appreciate the
difficulty I can't wait to see who the
bosses are mm-hmm
that giant ogre I think is this week
which seems yet but Nana's by the way
the way I saw them doing it for level
seven
basically seemed like they were up high
enough where most of the ground level
couldn't get them and they were the big
boys thanks oh these are in full effect
already oh yeah I mean those are the
people some people already 360 370 so I
mean they're to the point where it's
it's somewhat feasible not completely
like I'm their immune so I mean some
stuff I think would even be immune to me
right now so oh yeah sorry I feel like
you've gotten a long tangent there
you're good
so escalation protocol I haven't dabbled
in I don't think a whole lot of other
people have so those of you that have
will have more as we get to it so this
will be future topics for us the final
piece is what starts here in about two
hours
mmm which my my friends are very
everybody's very happy this is a long
point he's still up he's gonna do it
I'll finish just in time I'm sorry I
just passed out those two and now or I
laid down for a nap it turned into sleep
until the next morning just happens
though the spire of the Stars is the
final piece of content no one has seen
yet as of this recording yeah for you
guys as well I did not upload last week
so I'll probably put both of them up
together so just see that those will be
coming spire of the stars so we're going
up now I don't know how big this is
gonna be again I don't know how much
time they've had to develop I don't know
if this is apartment you know penthouse
apartment but I know because you've got
the living room in the bedroom and
that's it so I don't know what to expect
here hi well I hope there's at least
what cuz there's basically a jumping
puzzle with all little raising lowing
platforms and then there's our ghost you
have the flying through but it's those
two basically our goats has two phases
which is fine for a big-ass boss site
but in general
hopefully this raid lair has a little
more to offer yes or like it to be more
than like a two-degree won't encounter
possible if possible I'm gonna listen
the wall of me right now is like listen
as much as I've complained let's just
put a nice bow on this hold of Vienna
ding the kalos story let's just that's
all I'm asking Bungie look I get it you
guys double down on this Lane thing
you're gonna see it through you know
turn to the first two expansions I get
it you know please do justice to this
story do justice to the result you know
I would like some cinematics please you
know all that at least one if you can
grab one like somehow you're in calluses
like master bedroom and you're fighting
him in his like home court you know he's
got a lush master bedroom he's a fan
he's got the lady waving leaves he's
being fed great but you know and I was
trying to really read the cryptic you
know stuff and you know like find the
real source of my power and all this
stuff it please pay this off please I
mean that's all I can hope is that I'm
maybe I was just wrong and then that
they will have this great you know
cherry on the sundae beautiful way to
end it and we can put the conclusion of
the callous saga you know what a nice
little thing to it so Wilson try to be
able minded with you being expectations
temper expectations big time on now it's
a raid yep
so we'll see well here I mean just the
fact that the end of the first part of
Calais by the way if you haven't heard
this then you haven't played doesn't eat
spoilers
you're not aligning Calais mmm-hmm so
just the fact that they had that kind of
like little jab in your side be like hey
by the way you didn't actually kill the
raid boss yelling out crap
this was like that little bit I thought
that was actually kind of game trio that
was cool you know yeah I thought that
was actually really cooled a little
switch up but then once either world
came on like don't like this direction
you know that either world sent me but
left a bad taste I did not like how
short it was you know and I just didn't
feel any connection to Argos like it was
just like again clean out my basement
like no I don't want to clean out your
base no Callas I don't want to do that I
want to get back to this whole thing
that we were talking about you know yep
absolutely
so we'll see what comes with that one
that is the last piece that will drop I
do have new trials a few weapons a few
cosmetics you get the whale tail ship
the speeder looks cool the sparrow
you're actually digging that it opposed
looks like a podracer kind of open
engine type digging that weapons kind of
look cool looks like a submachine gun
shotgun scout possibly yes yeah so Chris
blanks from back definitely plenty of
grinding to do there I know he didn't
even spend that much time on those but
glory always goes up yeah
no glory is ranking that goes up and
down Valarie browser yeah I jumped in
one glory mansion it was against four
people on a team and one of them are you
look one of my team already left with
signal Travis later bye
I didn't even finish the match I don't
blame you say that yes yes yeah PC
player bases are de Graaff like we were
know so yeah and then I did too I did
like three matches one I won one I
joined in about literally a minute later
it was mercy nice
mercy oh sorry sorry
I jumped in and it was 63 to like 8 I
was like holy they need to be some type
of reward good sport reward for you
bonus I'm just like jumpy I was like all
right I'll just and then it was like 30
seconds laters finished it out I was
like okay that was a quick nothing but
that was for that was for valor so I got
like a small boost instead the streaks
in there cool like if you won five games
on our own you're running on teams then
you get more yeah
I like all these little all the pieces
and I think that's kind of my overall
this sets up the fall hopefully very
well I agree and I guess I played maybe
six match you started off one was my
first one was heartbreaking because I
think I we jumped out to like a 5-1 and
couldn't close the deal man it
infuriated me and I'm like this is how
I'm gonna lose my first minutes like it
was it was horrible
but um then after that kind of got
actually what I lacked had two losing
streak and after that like pull three in
a row sort of streak multiplied kick in
so it's gonna be sweaty it's gonna be
you know there's gonna be some anxiety
but I did enjoy it I mean and I actually
didn't have as much problem without no
Raider as I thought I did so um again I
know some people really hate that I'm
not gonna you know say if they're wrong
it's just look it's different you know I
love you know the fact that they've
added this mechanic into PvP it's way
more competitive and it's a I can't find
is that that desire to try to get to
that you know that that that glory level
to get that rhetorics you know if that
carrot is there you know what is that
incentive so that keeps me know and I
know I'm gonna get into it once I get
most of my PB e stuff done and my
sleeper simulant
yeah so I mean the grind the sleeper
I've seen some a couple videos on that
thing it's slightly different but it
still hits like a truck
so back yeah it's gonna be pretty brutal
so if you haven't grinded for that one
definitely look out there there's some
good guides out there it's gonna be
worth it yes for the sword yeah kind of
a cool grind like it's not overly
difficult like you don't have to go
fight some crazy extreme nightfall level
thing it's just gonna take some time
some hunting look on some YouTube
looking for guides so yeah what the I
mean there's stuff to go find there's
reasons to explore people had a reason
to not actually go play other things and
literally just explore I mean esoteric
did nothing but that he built his 45
thing guy that's all he was doing like
there was no reason to do that up until
now in all of destiny too so these are
good things really are I like it yeah so
I mean overall I have no idea what I
would grade this thing I mean some
pieces are good you know the strikes
kind of annoy me because of what they
are gonna loot from the strikes as well
you can't defeat the whole purpose but
the guns are feeling good I like the
secrets the story was short succinct
somewhat unsatisfying to me but it's
like tempered expectations yeah
tempered expectations are good for how
you feel when you get done so you don't
set it up too high but for a grade I
still feel like they did not even close
to knock it out of the park
no no way so what's your final grade
dude that's your letter letter what the
pluses and minuses
make it easy for me probably being
c-plus yeah I think it's in the bay
territory I don't think it's good to
qualify that you may have passed like
you may have passed but not well there
are some good things and with tempered
expectations that might be C plus C
minus depending on who you are
definitely better than curse of Osiris
gives us something different to do gives
us some grinding and I think the c-plus
if I see most improved students come
fall then that award will be justified
yes I will say this though for me it's
C+ like you because
son even there's some really good
building stuff and it's really like what
that was what's going on here but um I
will say this if the raid layer is good
it can get a B - if the raid layer
actually lives up to expectation and
closes and put a nice bow on it that's a
big deal for me because you know how I'm
not again I'm really against it so I I'm
gonna reserve judgment until I play it
go through it see that ending C+ for now
but got a shot at a B - if that really I
gotta be amazing I'm not even I don't
think even with that in there because
there's some things that are I don't
like as much
I reserve the right to review my score
but we'll talk next week and James now
are you are you gonna try and jump in
this weekend try it try the rate yeah
absolutely you just assume that's gonna
be level 300 I don't know what it's
gonna be honestly all I know is this I'm
gonna be grinding for that sleeper
before I started yeah I'm still probably
gonna spoil the raid just cuz I want to
know what's coming
yeah looks like I'm not too worried
about like you know cleaner run on this
one yeah so I'll check it out and see
definitely gonna feel even if I don't
run it I want to know what's going on in
it now what kind of give me an idea but
yeah I'll leave it a C+ for now I
reserve the right to come back but we'll
see
fair enough but I mean I think we
probably talked two years off long
enough we're creeping up towards two
hours it's an hour and 45 so it's a long
point you got some sleep to get to you
gotta try and basically get to bed
before anybody hurt her a baby
yes but yeah I mean overall the grind is
back there are some secrets the story
was you know short but to the point at
least you got a conclusion I'm gonna say
that there was
an actual conclusion yes first of a
cyrus basically I just tripped over that
bar so it's so well it's not hard to
beat for me yeah it's it's these are
it's better I just want to see the fall
I want to see this be a little baby
t-ball love I want to step them up into
the big leagues so I see them that's got
the ball that's what I want that's what
we won we want this to be the precursor
the positive baby step precursor to
knock it out of the park which is
hopefully we're banking on for from
everything we've heard on uh for fall
yep so every think that'll wrap it up
I've got a head out for a couple errands
or so but yeah I'll be around might get
a workout in or something later but I'll
be around for the weekends I know you
will be off and on as well we will be
back next week with thoughts about more
grinding maybe an escalation protocol
and that rate layer and yeah now III is
June alright yes
so that's insane oh yes coming up man I
got a lot of prep go on that's when you
figure out about the fall yeah because
you know they nounce
oh I totally forgot mode I mean I know
they mentioned it but it's actually like
even more public than just like podcast
now it's right so we'll see something
that has never been in a first-person
shooter I haven't the foggiest idea so
I'm just curious I'm loyal imagine gonna
be interesting yeah if they can't get
the fall to be amazing though and shadow
to Cronus and my dad he's been you with
us like most of the time he was like can
you mute it for the spoilers I was like
we're done he's like alright we're back
he says the fall is the maker rig for
the franchise and is to the point where
it's like I think that has to be because
my friends have already basically
checked out and if you can't win them
back again until it has a three on that
box I think they're out yeah I agree
if it does not hit every checkbox you're
out of there and I have no qualms and
saying it it has to be otherwise who
knows where disfranchise goes from that
point for it yep there's too many things
coming
I mean this is gonna compete with
spider-man on PlayStation as well
spider-man's like giant li anticipated
Call of Duty dead redemption had its
little trailer which division to anthem
it just the yeah it just keeps coming so
I got it's a it's a tough place to
compete now in the world of gaming so
you got to be good so we will see what
the future holds but three minute wrap
up later yeah thank you guys as always
for chat for support all you guys out
there on both sides of this whether it's
twitch or YouTube thank you guys we
always have fun busy it's nice to have a
whole bunch of random stuff to talk
about more to come yeah so we will
definitely be back next week similar
time at least is the plan unless
something crazy happens I don't know if
I'm working not yet so I'll still wait
to see what's in yeah
but outside of that we will be back soon
so enjoy your weekend guys have fun with
the grinds taking all the little pieces
as I put on Twitter it's the only thing
we're get for a little while so exactly
sip it in piece by piece look around the
nooks and crannies hunt for the puzzles
if you want to do the grind for all
those pieces of memory fragments and not
cheat yourself you got some stuff to
look for that stuff to do
absolutely yep and we still got a summer
update as well don't forget we still got
a No Fax rallies bounties exotic
masterworks exotic armor enormous yeah
but I mean yeah that's that I want to
see so me till tee-time alright guys
well that'll wrap it up thank you for
everything you follow for me it's twitch
Twitter YouTube it's abundance
everywhere so EB oh and tea is on
YouTube you guys know like subscribe hit
the alert Bell comment below thoughts
questions all that stuff we always
appreciate everything
yeah man and of course you know Glau
gaming and it comes in to check look at
him trying to tempt me to blaze the
Twitter you know to do on my podcast
every Sunday 1:00 p.m. Easter is the
Lord's Day we'll be back in the realm of
gaming should have it maybe a surprise
guest we'll keep you guys posted that's
gonna be on the inner circle gaming
Network YouTube channel and of course
stay tuned here always
every Thursday or Friday for flashpoint
with my man
each box is talking that destiny talk
that you love to hear always fun always
a pleasure when we're getting ready for
that a red lay and stuff to break down
next week all right
so goodbye good luck and to all of you
around the world good afternoon good
morning or good evening because I have
no idea where you're watching this from
or when so whatever time you're at
whenever time you're at if you were
listening this in the future then that's
actually kind of cool and today